dang do you have 39 million dollars
laying around you know I do well I know
where you should spend it at a penthouse
a New York wow let's check this baby out
it's gorgeous
[Music]
it looks like a psychiatric rooms are
just pure white and you don't know where
the wolves are yeah I feel like I've
stuck my toe on the edge of that sink
every time I walk through to the tub
yeah
I don't know if you saw a few frames
back but like the rooftop had a good
view of some scaffolding yeah what a
nice view good old scaffolding everyone
this I'm number one scaffolder hater
here in Japan they covered it up
see-through thing oh yeah that would be
nice that would be nice they even have a
decibel meter at some uh like bigger
constructions to show like oh we're not
making noise oh you can annoys pollution
but they have the meter there where it's
like
all right well let's check out this
wonderful investment
at 39 looks amazing so far welcome to 11
East 68th Street on the Upper East Side
in Manhattan this Penthouse has over 6
200 square feet and 26. is that big can
I don't know American thing 1600 square
feet yeah yeah it's pretty big all right
so good investment after all yeah like
like a good sized family house would be
probably around like 2 000 or 1 800
square feet so this thing's like pretty
big they covered everything with stone
huh out of those chairs I thought they
were TVs
they look so uncomfortable how do you
say on that it's got to be soft is that
is it a chair yes chairs they just
described it and went
I want to try the chair you're right
actually yeah so the location here could
not be better she's like Scandinavian
step from Center Park Madison Avenue
beautiful boutiques and restaurants
I would pay 39 million dollars do not
live in New York I was wondering what's
going to talk about this New York is
New York they're like oh I love it it's
so wonderful I'm like have you been in
it what what have you actually lived
there before I don't see what other
people see but I am willing to admit
maybe that has some charm so this pantas
has five bedrooms she said Panthers
she's definitely Scandinavian four
fireplaces three Terraces and of course
my favorite the beautiful outdoor
barbecue kitchen all this that's pretty
good yours for 39 million dollars yeah
wow sign me up
buys these I don't know I guess you're
paying for all the stone yeah everything
is just massive blocks of stone
everywhere
nice full bar with ice maker one
refrigerator and it's clad in this very
beautiful Onyx the Onyx is also backlit
with lighting so in the evening this
really stands out I think it's gonna go
no I'm glowing I want to Glow in marble
thing Onyx Onyx some Marvel notes Onyx
I'm already saying that I would love to
say that even though it's ugly as [ __ ]
how thin does it have to be to let the
light Even Shine through yeah right that
should mean it's cheap
can I see where the money went three
story staircase that is clad and marble
it is surprise more stoned again yeah
we're still this is like the coldest
house that's why they have five
fireplaces because this place is
freezing
but they're not even fireplaces they're
like those electronic ones no yeah yeah
yeah there's a gas I don't know we also
have a very unique feature within oh
it's got an outdoor fireplace
so you're outside entertaining you can
look at your fire and you're
entertaining inside you will see it too
that's actually kind of cool I want to
double-sided fireplace I want a 360
fireplace 360.
I was just thinking about how everything
is Stone I wonder if like your feet hurt
walk around this house just because like
we have like hardwood floor or whatever
they usually have like a little pad on
the bottom of them to make it uh like a
shock absorbent a little bit bottom
floor Old Stone I hate it like on my
feet am I just older Maybe
do you love it uh what's alone she's so
I mean it's just a big block but I'm not
the the freaking green thing she's
talking about looks like it needs to be
trimmed or something it's got stuff
hanging all over it and then what good
is the fireplace if you can't feel the
fire outside oh yeah does it Blow heat
out or something it looks like uh
something I would build in Minecraft you
know you have all this extra Stone and
we're like I don't know what to do with
his material but it looks cool I guess
I'll put it in whole seating area for
cocktails oh the chairs just feel
uncomfortable they looked horrible ah
everything looks like my back would hurt
just staring at it look at that look at
this metal
oh my butt but he's got holes in it oh
so my my fat can hang through them I
guess you get a POV underneath that you
get up and you have like markings on
your like a stamp on your butt like oh
before we continue quick word from
sponsor stop right there that's G fuel
you're drinking right now good G fuel
the world's greatest drink look God
himself blesses it look how beautiful
already finished mine do g-fuel is now
out with a new collab can you guess in
foreign
it looks just like Pac-Man that's gonna
say that's the thing looks like Pac-Man
and if you get the collector box it lits
up just like Pac-Man that's kind of cool
the Pac-Man flavor is Cherry lollipop do
you feel always kills it with the
flavors it's available now to pre-order
and don't hesitate because the Gundam
collector went right away so if you want
it don't hesitate and use the code
PewDiePie to get 20 off and now is the
time to stock up on G feel because this
entire month of January you get 30 off
if you use the code PewDiePie if you
haven't tried G fuel before I recommend
trying out a starter kit there's a ton
that you can pick from and you get to
find which flavors you prefer which is
PewDiePie flavor that was The Taste it's
only PewDiePie flavor just kidding I've
been drinking the Elden ring one it's
really good it's a pear flavor honestly
I've yet to have a bad one they're
always so good love G fuel 30 off use
the link in description take this
advantage to stock up that's it formal
dining with a fire pit oh there's a fire
pit hey there you go Ken are you happy
now yeah it's like the well they call it
when you're like go to like the is it a
Hibachi they got the guy in the middle
of like cook stuff and flips it to you
it's almost like all right without the
guy so now you're now you're in on the
39 million again yeah now that's all I
need to know that and this room that has
like a freaking I don't know the thing
is on the left beside the bed some Blair
Witch burnt wood
is that this primary bedroom is
unbelievable we have this Japanese maple
wolf I was just gonna say it is a
Japanese style to do that it's like I
see it a lot actually but they never
code it my favorite this Atelier window
that was custom designed just for this
Penthouse and the view you can see half
of Manhattan Island
wow I always feel weird like people are
watching me and they are I remember
going to a friend's house flying like
this he had binoculars right there she's
like yeah I love to spy on people I'm
like it's a little
weird to be honest at the very top floor
there's a bunch of Windows and I do have
a pair of binoculars but I used it to
look out at the ocean
and not it what do you look at the ocean
like for Sirens what are you looking for
well I can also see the park that my
kids play at from there too so I can use
that he's quiet the kids yeah like okay
anybody
going towards a park right
oh no
whoa hold on a second no no that's kind
of cute actually like they're having so
much fun without me why aren't you just
going with them instead of spying on
your [ __ ] kids I'm not spawn on them
I'm just like all right well let's see
are they are they I don't know just to
look I have to leave the house I don't
leave the house we have very big windows
in our house and they didn't have any
tint on them when we first got the house
like you could just literally you know
from that same park you could look into
my house and just see like the whole
like second floor so other people are
sprying on you is that what you're
saying yeah so I installed like some I
had I had a guy come and install like
some uh reflective tent on the windows
in the house now they can't see inside
anymore but I can see them
but that only works if it's brighter
outside than it is inside
Mmm Yeah it's still dark enough to where
it kind of helps a little bit but yeah
that's good a beautiful planted Terrace
with maybe that's why people live in New
York so they can just spy on other
people they're all on the roofs looking
each other right now yeah but yeah the
top is like Batman looking at you so let
me show you now the two dressing rooms
too that is ensuite to the bedroom
let me guess Stone no oh God I I okay
you know I have somebody thoughts they
just had something to break up the same
pattern over and over again it would
look a lot better but it's just like
this Big Blob of the same thing yeah
it's a cool technique with the burnt
wood but it just looks so bad when it's
all over the place this dressing room is
like for the Stars storage Galore I mean
my God this is a dream storage Galore I
am Swedish I promise no I'm not Swedish
help me
that looks terrible yeah he place your
wallet in there it's lost forever you'll
never find it it's like camouflage it's
just gone yeah I want to see the toilet
where's it at where is it
something that you will never see again
you have this it's probably in there
somewhere in the same material book
Matched you have all nickel Hardware
door and break fixtures radiant heated
floors thank God of course the
freestanding tub dual water closet
another shower what can I say I just I
would never leave this bathroom I want
to leave as soon as I enter
side by side though you know two people
can go in there just blow it up and high
five each other yeah good job bro that's
why you're paying 39 mil right there now
we're up here on the third level which
is nice Solarium that is actually set up
as a
as it now
picking that room that's getting way too
[ __ ] hard right I don't have
everything else in here looks super cold
so maybe it bounces out this gym should
be a nice art studio I can't lift any
heavy weights in here I'd knock a window
I'll die you know I'll be squatting
go right out the window and everyone
everyone with their binoculars can see
when you're in there exercising they
were like oh he's taking way too long
between reps look at that form
you also have a full marble bathroom up
here and where's the toilet I don't oh
there there it is is that a built-in
trash canvas on it it's gonna be a black
one right
it's above it I can't I can't everything
is black I can't [ __ ] tell you what
oh it is it is a trash can
[Music]
be nice that actually yeah it looks nice
it's a couple of different materials
what's the floor is it like dirty carpet
what is that they are done here at the
main is that rug on the wall what is
that
they're like uh yeah we we need the
stone to cover everywhere with no soft
surfaces put it on the wall get the
carpet on the wall get it off the floor
what do you do I love the layout over
here it just flows naturally between the
dining room the great room I don't even
know where okay I'm completely lost in
this area kitchen let's start here in
the dining area this is the place you
can entertain 20 of your best friends
laughs
20.
20.
how often are you getting my 20 [ __ ]
people over
get the [ __ ] out of here I mean I guess
when you have 39 million dollars to
spend in a penthouse like this you have
20 best friends all of a sudden you know
it's I don't want 20 people ever near me
what the [ __ ]
actually ties into the wet bar that has
this beautiful marble as well look it's
more marble Ken wow more more expensive
Stone right
that's nice because it's expensive okay
you don't understand what the [ __ ] is
that behind us
this comes from the grass tribe you know
we and the Warriors you have the stone
custom table with metal that ties into
the metal cord I mean it's unbelievable
more Stone
more Stone more stuff
even the fireplace logs were stuck
I have the dining room door and we are
now in great room oh hard it's literally
metal dude is it Rusty oh yeah what the
hell is that we have tetanus shot just
to sit on it
ever forbid you like slip all like your
feet are wet you know on the the marble
floor and you you stab your face yeah
expensive chairs that's the problem the
views are unbelievable you have full set
of views and you also have which is very
unique Central Park views the
continuation
wonderful wonderful view between these
two buildings here like look at that I
can see it I can see it
we had in our first flight where you
could see the ocean like if you stood on
this one specific spot
and they showed it no I don't know it's
just like obviously they make it a point
when you're you're viewing the property
but it's like I don't think I ever even
looked at it from that angle ever look
you can see a bunch of dead trees if you
stand right here oh wow yes the
continuation of the beautiful
attribution just on the dining room we
also have all custom designed Furniture
just put the space that is so that's why
they're so ugly they can they're made
for this space all right I got some
broken glass here put some glue just
press it on yeah that's what it looks
like oh look and make the space so
lavish now let's take a look at this we
have the breakfast room right behind oh
the couch
they can't like the couch cushion on the
bottom right it's like my butt is so
thin oh
my whole body hurts just imagine living
here oh
if I'm paying 39
39 at least a pool or like oh it's a
song I want all these weird random [ __ ]
but they had a sauna they had a sauna oh
okay we're good we're good
oh is that the same thing
I gotta go Ken what what wait what I'm
not because I can't believe you think
steam room and sound like the same thing
what do you mean that you sit down like
when you sit down with a bunch of naked
old men and throw some water on the
rocks and it's the sauna right it yeah
that's a sign okay we get but then the
theme room is still the same
what's the difference I don't know when
does this have the old man naked old men
in it yeah I guess so yeah if there's
not a naked man with hanging balls take
a look at the kitchen the kitchen is
very special here indeed it's down by
Saint Charles no one said that you can
just say that we said that it's kind of
cool actually I mean it looks like a
really nice like servant kitchen yeah
it's kind of weird it looks like that
because it's kind of crazy which is one
of the best and they only do custom work
so yes as you can see you have this
beautiful metal cabinets the incredibly
nice layout you have this is a toolbox
it's already scratched and stained it
looks like a toolbox like yeah you're
right it does it's like 39 million I
don't want stains on my thing already
what are all these faucets for what is
all this it's not even properly clean
yeah well there are so many faucets
[Music]
wow
so we are still here on the first
Library there's no books in here you
can't call it a libraries
there is an access point to a full
bathroom so if you want to where is it I
can't see it
why does that table look like candy bars
for layout ample space for office work
entertaining if you have a fireplace
this exotic Woods that's imported from
Africa just absolutely beautiful
I'm good
is that dead oh
more Stone huh kids would just die here
it's like a death try this room is
really interesting you have these two
chances that are custom designed
beautiful Metals Onyx and onyx
it's Alex
just like that Pokemon
that's so cool this is made from this
dead family they constructed this
building out of it now this room
actually was a bedroom originally so if
you want to convert it back to a bedroom
you can easily juice well I know I can
do whatever I want what does that mean
it's gonna cost me another 40 million
what do you you got to pay somebody a
lot to move all this stuff
ton of more money to make the room
different
what no stop it right next to the media
room we have the what is this the home
what
oh
Stone turds gather up and cutting out
I mean
you have the African bush oh dude I saw
a ninja mask back there 39 million
dollars I use an HP laptop please
[Laughter]
you have the African wood beautiful
views and this was a bedroom originally
so if you want to make this a bedroom
again you can easily do so no way I can
turn the room if there's something else
49 million 39 right here you go no
freaking way dude and if you want to
tear down the entire thing and redo the
entire layout yeah you can't do that as
well we are in the bedroom Wing now
where we have dual bedrooms they are
pretty identical oh those stairs are so
ugly
those chairs or tables what do you do in
this room this is the room you call
there and guess what if you want you can
turn this into a kitchen a kitchen yeah
[Music]
joining me here today
I'll take it yeah I'll take it yeah as
long as they take out these p-colored
yellow chairs I'll be
again
yeah
I know in my life that's so great
I guess one thing that being rich can't
get you is a sense of style good god oh
if you know this video check out Ken
check out me or you're already here
subscribe see you next video